et attention c'est parti c'est le fond
du court
[Applaudissements]
dumas
oui
[Applaudissements]
aussi je suis
[Musique]
il
tél
[Musique]
nerfs du spectateur en plus
avant les séries les belles âmes à la
merci est le ballon c'est mon pote qui
les fait bravo merci très beau très très
bon allez c'est parti on y va vite vous
tirer tous d'accord on va prendre les
gens on va prendre tout le premier rang
là venez vite vite vite et venez je vous
le dis c'est quoi
on va voir c'est quoi on va tous tirés
en fait si on a un kilo mais on off
10000 euros au public ah oui y'a
quelqu'un du public qu'on tirera au sort
d'accord les cherry et attention c'est
parti à lévis depuis les fenêtres ce
talent dit on y va vite
dix mille
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on
[Musique]
allez
[Applaudissements]
c'est fou quand on écoute et vtt
mais que c'est bon
impossible
[Musique]
il a battu l agile que
[Applaudissements]
à temps et est redit si tu le mets
la pression ne t'a pas de mots ce film
neil tu tapes il écoute moi bien
renchérit si c'est rudy mais le panier
tu repars avec cent mille dirhams 10000
euros au frère je sais mais c'est un
honneur mais c'est pas encore gagné mais
l'important c'est le geste qui compte
ça lui arrivait quand même oui il
poursuit c'est parti bonsoir merci et
les quelques attentions avant le tir de
rudy attends attends rappelle el zaytoun
c'est l'album d'elsa qui cartonne en ce
moment
merci elsa d'avoir avec l'abbé vincent
j'te kiffe j'adore quand il as we dit on
va te retrouves au championnat du monde
bien en tant qu'adjoint 2 et 6 et tu
sais qu'on t'aime et on se retrouve avec
le utah jazz
attention rue dit si tu le mets tu veux
combien d'essayer d'y aller on met deux
essais bah oui oui à l'érudit
[Applaudissements]
alors fait trois essais trois escrocs
fait on fait trois essais à ta chance et
tu es bon le 01 juin dans des attentats
zéro on peut arrêter la musique de
minutes que je parlais aux gars ça
m'arrange pas du tout pour les 10
millions c'est pas parce qu'en fait ça
maintenant allez c'est parti
dix mille euros 0,10 tu l'aimés si tu
les mets notre ami repart avec des ions
sodium
attention attention c'est le dernier
c'est le dernier
concentre-toi j'ajoute un dîner avec moi
si tu le mets
qu attend
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
hu
ça sera